before we get started fear not this is a
spoiler free review no spoilers here I
need to get that out of the way since
the movie came out what two weeks ago
for everyone outside the United States I
finally saw it America x-men apocalypse
so x-men apocalypse is the newest x-men
movie directed by Bryan Singer in this
one the first mutant ever was a guy
named enca banner and he was in ancient
Egypt he's been asleep now he has awoken
he's gonna wreak some so now he has
four mutants with him who are the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse and the x-men
need to come together and stop him I
said spoiler free so that's what you get
right now first of all let's talk about
what I liked in the movie Oscar Isaac as
apocalypse was a pretty menacing dude
goes to show you when a photo first
comes out of a comic book villain and
you hate it don't jump the gun quite yet
I try to do that myself I'm not always
innocent of it sometimes my god
that but I am trying to remember
that these are the preliminary photos
and they're not always going to
illustrate what's going to happen in the
movie or what it's gonna look like in
the movie because nothing about his look
really bothered me I thought he was
pretty cool looking one thing that did
bother me about apocalypse that doesn't
do with Oscar Isaac physically speaking
he wasn't that big and menacing there's
a scene where he's standing next all of
his horsemen and he's the smallest one
of them it's kind of a problem when
you're supposed to be the big baddie in
this huge apocalyptic apocalypse saga of
x-men apocalypse did I say apocalypse
enough because that's what we're dealing
with here I did backup me like couldn't
you do the effect they did with Xerxes
and 300 just make him look like he's
towering over everybody I mean 15
years ago in Fellowship of the Ring they
did that with Aragorn and hobbits any of
the humans in the hobbits that made them
bigger than them use camera tricks use
green screen it can happen so just
baffled me that his size wasn't more
accommodating for how menacing he's
supposed to be in this movie had some
sick powers oh he can literally change
the molecular composition of anything so
I gotta turn you to dust far out your
dust which does pose a problem for the
concept of apocalypse and tension in
this movie you've seen that apocalypse
can literally take solid matter and turn
it into dust so any time he doesn't turn
any of the x-men into dust when they're
causing him problems he's just being an
idiot and it's kind of a mixed bag for
me but anything that had to do with
magneto is where the fields are coming
from some of the other character
is not as much as magneto but you're
looking at Magneto and you'll owe the
fields are happening in quite a few
scenes that being said that is along
with the build-up of the movie the
build-up does take some time there's
some pacing issues in this movie I first
you like alright its apocalypse is past
then you got magneto
and it's a big recruiting process
mystique is looking for mutants
apocalypse is looking for me so many
mutants to find so little time and it's
an hour into the movie let's get
going and I get the x-men movies are
ultimately a showcase there are so many
x-men in the comics that you want to see
new ones in the new movies for sure at
this stage in the game it gets a little
convoluted when you want to include
x-men that we've already seen be it some
recast and then including new Lex
marriage is there a lot of pieces on the
board some shine more than others and
sophie turner really impressed me as
Jean Grey in this movie I'm looking
forward to more x-men movies having
sophie Turner is Jean Grey whenever they
recast somebody and have the young face
or was like it's gotta be oh yeah sophie
turner was really good and storm
actually had an accent in this movie
Halle Berry kind of had it and the first
one kind of and then just went away
let's talk about Quicksilver Quicksilver
once again has another sweet-ass speed
scene it's great it's like they knew the
first one they were like hey man got to
do it again so they do it again and it
was a cool ass thing and he plays a
larger role in this movie than he did in
the last movie I like that damage it I
just like Evan Peters as Quicksilver one
thing that really did bother me in this
movie the thing that fans have started
to be like hey I don't like that I don't
like that and finally I'm on the boat of
yeah alright enough to know if I don't
like that either it's Jennifer
Lawrence as Mystique's not necessarily
Jennifer Lawrence as mystique but what
they're doing with Jennifer Lawrence as
mystique it's like they know Jennifer
Lawrence is Jennifer Lawrence's face so
they can't make it blue any time they
found a reason to have mystique actually
looked like blue face mystique you know
mutant and proud and that whole speech
she gave in x-men first class they found
a reason to turn her back into Jennifer
Lauren because you know Jennifer
Lawrence she's in baby she's in it and
now it's officially irritating me but
honestly guys I mean the movie is a fun
time to have cool destructive
apocalypse is ski mag of like yeah
that's bad news don't do that x-men
stop them the stakes are high in this
movie as they should be there's some
solid fanservice in this movie too if
you know what you're looking at you're
like oh holy that's awesome
one scene they actually spoiled in one
of the trailers I don't want to tell you
what it is but they spoiled it in a
trailer they didn't show it in the
trailer it would have been so awesome to
see for the first time just in this
movie yeah when you spoil your
fanservice in a trailer kind of defeats
the point of fanservice x-men apocalypse
if I can put it frankly and simply is
like this it's entertaining but lacks a
lot of the depth that x-men days of
future past and x-men first class both
had for me personally not that it
doesn't have character depth in it it's
just all of it's more or less tied in
with Magneto and that's what you get it
does have some pacing issues but never
to the point where it pissed me off
I was entertained for most of this movie
I actually had to pee for the last half
of the movie didn't want to get up
that's more or less how I judge whether
or not the movie is entertaining me and
grabbing me is whether or not I can call
it and be like yeah gotta pay it's fine
I'm out
admittedly I haven't seen x-men 1 and 2
in many years but as I remember it x-men
first class Days of Future past x-men 1
and x-men 2 are all better than x-men
apocalypse for me but x-men apocalypse
is still way better than x-men origins
Wolverine in x-men 3 for sure still a
great time I was entertained if you're
an x-men movie fan you should check it
out I will say x-men apocalypse is a
good time no alcohol required and yeah
this weekend I'll have a spoiler talk
for x-men apocalypse all the things I
really couldn't cover in this review so
I'm like I don't wanna ruin that I don't
wanna okay this is generally what I
think of it without spoiling for
you I'll cover in that video but for
right now x-men apocalypse have you seen
it what did you think about it what's
your favorite and least favorite x-men
movies thus far whatever they are
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you